yeah that's the that's the sweet spot
you know you you know you really hit it
with you know for you to manage Optimal
Performance and health
um especially as you get older it it
does become a full-time job like I was
thinking about this the other day I was
you know I was thinking how much money
and time do I spend every week on
training boxing supplements
um you know prescriptions that I gotta
take
um treatments yeah IV treatments
sticking to the routine it's a lot like
you know real real quick I you know I
have a personal trainer now that I deal
with twice a week he's a former
bodybuilder used to coach
um a coach but um uh
rate or grade you know bodybuilders on
stage
yeah judge and you know like he was the
kind of guy that's like okay you know
before we get started because I'm like I
just want to balance myself out right he
goes okay so you know before we get
started just you know strip down your
boxes all right so you're standing he's
like all right your adults suck your
hamstrings are [__] pathetic your
calves need work but I think we should
fix all this right yeah so I'm like yeah
that's what I need like I need that guy
I don't want to you know like so there's
that then I do boxing twice a week and
then I learned that box is
counter-intuitive to this building
strengthened muscle because you can be
saying you know if I'm going to build
your legs you can't be walking ten
thousand twenty thousand you know cut
that back right I'm like okay so that's
interesting I didn't know that either
and then you have to deal with you know
weekly IV treatments because now I'm
doing an IV bag every Friday with
glutathione then I alternate that with
phosphocholine what's that yeah what
what is in your IV bag because I just
started this about a year ago and I'm
I'm fascinated I want people to take
yeah honestly yeah mine's um a mixture
of vitamins so B vitamin C vitamins
um you know like a cocktail of that then
it's a cocktail of some amino acids so
muscle building aminos uh nitric oxide
boosting like L-Arginine l-citrulline
encounters it with some immune Health
stuff like a L-lysine you know so
there's this whole cocktail of like
aminos and they squirt in the bag the
glutathione so that's one week and then
the alternating week I do um
uh phosphocholine which is really good
for you know cleaning up heavy metals in
your body cleaning out
um you know things that are in your
arteries blockages fats whatever you
know
um so it has a lot of enhancements on
cardiovascular health sexual performance
all that sort of stuff right so
that's a lot and then you have to deal
with the the diet because yeah sugar
tastes good right yeah I know so we all
know that carbs taste good weeks of
sugar in America yeah and you know when
you're 25 you can get away with smoking
a big fat joint eating a bag of Doritos
smashing it back with a protein shake
and wake up in the morning and look
ripped every day
but when you get older you really have
to pay attention your diet right you
have to pay attention to the carbs you
have too everything I I think as
entrepreneurs you kind of cursed in that
way because you're just so busy grinding
that you're actually sitting in the same
spot that's the other problem 10 hours
12 hours per day whereas when you were
dead broke teenager or 20 year olds you
walked everywhere so you got your steps
in and I think that was part of the
reason why I stayed so lean I don't know
how
financially secure you were when you
were 20 but I broke not so much yeah
it's broke right so so you walk to the
bus right you take public transportation
you walk here you walk there you go to
university you walk around there all day
and that that helps to keep you lean you
can eat pizza every day and it's fine
yeah you sit on your your butt every day
you know trying to work and grow your
business yeah my diet back then was oh
[__] you know McDonald's has uh what do
they have yeah
have bacon cheeseburgers on sale
right
five or six bacon cheeseburgers and just
smash those back right and you still
look good like you know you could still
manage your body would still manage to
process it and turn it into muscle it
didn't matter when you were young but
when you get older it's a lot like like
you said the older you get it becomes
more of a full-time job like the amount
of time and money that I because
I want to represent masculinity and
strength when I'm talking to guys like I
tell guys do the [__] work pick up
heavy [__] learn how to fight I would be
a hypocrite if I didn't do the work
myself right you know I tell guys you
know manage your blood Labs that's the
other thing too managing your blood Labs
I mean I get my blood pulled every three
you know three and a half months you
look at guys too right yeah I do it all
the time I mean yeah mine every month
because I'm in Thailand monthly every
day yeah I can do a monthly if I want
wow because I run the experiments you
know and I I like to stay on top of my
health and I've you know I've made
plenty of mistakes regarding PEDs in the
past yeah so I just got to stay on top
of my [__] and
um you know yeah if people need help
with blood work analysis yeah I'm always
available for consultations
it's amazing how your body changes too
because it's like yeah you know one of
the things I learned over the last few
years watching your videos and the other
guys that you've worked with in the past
as well is that kidneys are very
sensitive to androgens you know
especially
um and kidneys seem to be the first
thing that go when you're lifting heavy
weight stress in your body you consume a
lot of protein and you take androgens
like you know even even therapeutic
testosterone at those levels you know
you really have to be mindful so I mean
if you're taking Peds or if you're on
trt and you're not managing your blood
properly you could really end up in a
situation where your organ Health
suffers and like you see guys die very
quickly you know what it gets in there
so when you when your kidneys filled the
heart fails and liver fails quite
rapidly after that right and people
always blame particular steroids like
golden owners keeping toxic or
trimbalones kidney toxic or Deanna bowls
could be toxic the only reason why they
mention those compounds is because the
studies have been performed but when you
look at the the steroid family as a
whole you can't really find studies
performed on primobolin or mastron or
other PDS regarding Kidney Health well
we do know is that kidney disease is
more prominent in men because androgens
including testosterone are not so good
for kidney Health that's why naturally
your testosterone levels Decline and
that's why what you see with pits for
example I just got six cats so I really
started hammering into the pits you see
that with cats and dogs when they get
neutered castrated they have less
incense of kidney disease less less
issues regarding that so as a
bodybuilder or even somebody else on trt
you're basically actively trying to
damage your kidneys even by staying on
tr3 even though the quality of life
improves substantially right trt is
great great for business great for
productivity great to keep your libido
at older age men this there's a million
benefits of trt but you really need to
manage your blood pressure because even
keeping these testosterone levels at you
know higher levels than you would
produce naturally might be you know not
so good for your Kidney Health now again
long-term data regarding trt and Kidney
Health I wasn't really able to piece
that together you know conclusively
um but yeah I think anybody on trt or
men in general blood pressure management
is the lowest hanging fruit you can pay
attention to more important than hair
loss more important than libido issues
more important than gyno or acne blood
pressure management
that's the most important thing any man
can look at you can do it you can do it
with cardio you can do it with
supplements you can do it with your diet
you can do it by de-stressing which is
the probably the hardest and then
there's medication to manage it and
whether that's Cialis you know or or
tell massartan and Angiotensin receptor
blocker I mean there's so many methods
to control your blood pressure so
anybody that walks around with high
blood pressure now unless it's
hereditary and even then it's
addressable
I don't I don't see a reason why you
know unless you're morbidly obese and in
fact is kind of compressing your veins
you know that's also a reason for high
blood pressure or sleep sleep apnea so I
think blood pressure if you can address
that you're already light years ahead
yeah there was a there was an
interesting video I saw somewhere I
can't remember who who did it to offer
the credit but
um I think the longest known study
they've ever done on androgens and and
Kidney Health was kind of accidental
there was some uh I think they were
Korean monks and and it was a time where
they would uh castrate them right so
they basically yeah yeah and I think
they found that that the Korean monks
that were Unix basically lived something
like 30 or 35 percent longer than the
general population because they didn't
have their nuts and because you know you
don't have nuts you don't have
testosterone antigens which improves
your Kidney Health but but I think that
you know the question really is is okay
you know maybe you can live 35 longer as
a eunuch but why would you want to like
the entire Point yeah 50 50 quality of
life yeah like I would like I would
rather knock a few years off the end and
live better you know during my prime
years and live an extra like 35 longer
to like 110 or something like that with
no Johnson you know what I mean so what
I would say is if you if you decide to
go this route trt trt Plus or TT plus
plus plus which is usually what it ends
up anyway I had a little bit of this a
little bit of that you're just let's say
you're live 100 years and you compress
that into
75 years of a higher quality
that's that's how I looked at it so you
actively make your life shorter but the
quality of your life during this shorter
time is substantially higher than
anybody else and I would not trade that
for the world yeah now will I will I
regret it at 75 years old and you know
the clock is ticking on me
who knows I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out